The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
MARTEN VAN DIJK: So today we're
going to talk about relations.
We're going to talk
about partial orders.
Wow this is loud.
Could you put it a bit softer?
So we're going to
talk about relations,
partial orders, and then
parallel task scheduling.
So well, we'll start out with
a few definitions as usual
and examples will explain what
you're talking about here.
So what about relations?
Well, relations are
very simple definition.
A relation from a
set A to a set B
is really a subset of the
cross product of the two.
So let me give an example.
It's a subset R that has its
elements in a cross product
of A and B, which really
means that it has pairs where
the first element
is drawn from A
and the second
element is from B.
So for example, if you're
thinking about the classes
that you're taking as say,
set B and all the students
set A, well, then
you can describe
this is as a relationship
where we have tuples
a, b where a student
a is taking class b.
So a relation is really
just a set of pairs.
The first part of the pair is
in set A, the second one in B.
Now, we will use
different notation
for indicating that a
pair is in this subset,
so we'll be talking
about further properties,
then it will become more
clear, but we will also write
that a is to relate this to b.
So instead of the pair
a, b is an element of R,
you may write a R b,
or we say a and then
we use this symbol
with a subscript R b.
So we use the relational
symbol in between a
and b in these two cases.
And the reason for
that becomes clear
if you start talking
about the properties,
but let me first give
a few more examples
and talk about the
types of relations
that you're really
interested in.
We really are interested
in a relation on a set A,
and this is really
a subset R that
is a cross product
of A with itself.
So essentially, A is equal
to B in the definition
right up here.
Now, examples that we
have for this one is,
for example, we may have A
to B, all in the integers,
positive and negative, and
then we can say, for example, x
is related to y if
and only if x is,
for example, congruent
to y modulo 5.
This would be a proper relation.
We have not yet talked
about special properties.
We will come to that.
Other examples
are, well, we could
take all the positive
integers, 0, 1, and so on
and so forth, and
then right so x
is related to y if and
only if, for example, you
could say that x defines y.
That's another relationship
that we could use.
Notice, by the way that
in the correct [INAUDIBLE]
that I put here, I already
used sort of relational symbols
right in the middle
between x and y over here.
So that's already
indicating why we are using
a notation that I put up here.
So another example
is, for example,
we have that x is related to y
if and only if x is at most y.
This is also a relation.
So now what are the
special property that we
are interested in and those
that will make relations
special and then we can
talk about-- actually,
I forgot one item
that we will talk
about as well, which
are equivalents
classes, equivalence relations.
So we will see when we
talk about the properties
right now that we
will be defining
very special types
of relations and we
will talk about these
two, equivalents relations
and partial orders.
So what are the properties?
Actually before we go
into those properties,
let us just first describe what
the relationship, how we can
describe it in a different way.
Actually relation is nothing
more than a directed graph,
like R over here is a subset
of a cross product with a.
So that's pairs and you can
think of those as being edges.
So let us write it down as well.
So set A together with
R is a directed graph.
And the idea is very simple.
The directed graph has
vertices V and edge set
E where we take V to be equal to
A and the edge set equal to R.
So for example, we could
create a small little graph,
for example, for three
persons, Julie and Bill
and another one, Rob.
And suppose that
the directed edges
indicate whether one
person likes the other.
So for example Julie likes
Bill and Bill likes himself,
but likes no one else.
Julie also likes Rob,
but does not like herself
and Rob really likes Julie,
but does not like himself.
So for example, you
could create a graph
where all the directed edge
really represent the relations
that you have described by R.
So we will use this later on
and the special properties
that we are interested
in are the following.
So the properties are that
relations can be reflexive.
So a relation R
on A is reflexive
if x is related to itself for
all x, so for all x in A. Well,
for example, in this particular
graph, that is not the case.
If Julie and Rob would
also like themselves,
then the relationship up here
would actually be reflexive.
We have symmetry, so we call
a relationship symmetric
if x likes y, then that should
imply that y also likes x
and it should, of course,
hold for all x and y.
We have a property that
we call antisymmetric,
which is the opposite of this.
Antisymmetric means that if x
likes y and y likes x, then x
and y must be the same.
So this really
means that it's not
really possible to
like someone else
and that someone
else also likes x,
because according to the
antisymmetrical property,
that would then imply that
x is actually equal to y.
So these two definitions are
opposite from one another.
And the final one that we're
interested in is transitivity.
So the relationship is
transitive if x likes y and y
likes z, then x also likes z.
So let's have a look
at these few examples
and see whether we can figure
out what kind of properties
they have.
So let's make a
table and let's first
consider that x
is congruent to y
modulo 5 and next divisibility
and the other one is less than
or equal to.
So are they reflexive
is the first question
and they we want to
know whether they're
symmetric and antisymmetric
and transitive.
So what about this
one over here?
So can you help me figure
out whether they're
reflexive and symmetric or
antisymmetric and transitive?
What kind of properties
does this one have?
So when we look at x is
congruent to y modulo 5,
it really means that the
difference between x and y
is divisible by 5.
So is it reflexive?
Is x congruent to x modulo 5?
It is right.
That's easy.
So we have yes.
Now, if x is congruent
to y module 5,
is y also congruent
to x modulo 5?
It is because the
difference between x and y
is divisible by 5
and stays the same.
So y is congruent to x as well.
So it is symmetric.
Now what about
the antisymmetric?
If x is congruent to
y modulo 5 and y is
congruent to x modulo 5, does
that mean that x is equal to y?
It's not really true, right?
You can give a
counterexample for that.
So for example, we could have
that 7 is congruent to 2 modulo
5 and 2 is congruent to 7 modulo
5, but they're not the same.
So this is not true.
No.
What about transitivity?
Is this true?
So let's consider
this example as well.
So if I have that 2 and 7 are
congruent to one another modulo
5, well, 7 is also, for example,
congruent to 12 modulo 5.
Does it mean that 2 and 12
are congruent to one another?
So we have 2 is
congruent to 7 modulo 5.
We have, say 7 is
congruent to 12 modulo 5.
Well, we can look at
the difference between 2
and 12, which is 10,
is also divisible by 5.
So actually this does imply that
2 is congruent to 12 modulo 5.
Now, this is, of
course, not a proof
because this is just
by example, but you
can check for yourself that
this relationship is actually
transitive.
Now, what about divisibility.
Maybe you can help
me with this one.
So is it reflexive?
Is this right?
I hear yes.
That's correct because if x
and y equal to one another,
well, it's 1 times x, so x
divides x, so that's true.
Is it symmetric?
So if x divides y and y
divides x, so let's just see.
We are over here.
So if x divides y, does
that imply that y divides x?
That's the relation
that we want to check.
Is that true?
Not really.
We can have like say 3 divides
9, but 9 does not divide 3,
so this is not true,
but antisymmetry.
So if x defies y and
also y divides x,
then they must be
equal to one another.
So we can see that this
actually is antisymmetric,
so that's interesting.
And transitivity, well, we
have, again, transitivity
because if x divides y and
y divides z, then x also
divides z.
For example, if 2 divides,
say 4 and 4 divides 20,
then 2 also divides 20.
Now this one over here has
actually the same properties
as divisibility.
It's reflexive because x is
at least equal to itself.
It's not symmetric
because if x is at most y,
does not really imply
that y is at most x,
so this particular relation
does not hold, in general,
but it is, again,
antisymmetric because if I
have this inequality
and the other one, well,
x and y must be equal to
one another in that case
and transitive as well.
Now, it turns out that
in these examples,
we have seen a certain
combination of properties
that we will be talking about.
The kind of combination
that we see here
will lead to a definition
of equivalence classes,
equivalence relations, and this
is also a very usual pattern,
and this we will define
as partial orders.
So this is what we are
going to talk about next.
So we'll first start with
equivalence relations,
so let's do this.
What is an equivalence relation?
An equivalence
relation is exactly
a relation that has those
few properties over there.
So there's reflexive,
symmetric, and transitive.
So an equivalence relation is
reflexive and also symmetric
and also transitive.
So we've already
seen some examples
up there or one example, but
a very trivial relation, maybe
you can think of one that
is really straightforward.
What will be an
equivalence relation
if you think about how we write
mathematical formulas down?
We usually like the
equality sign also.
So just equality the equal
sign itself is actually
one example and
the other example
is the one that we have
there and that's, of course,
more general.
We can have x is
congruent to y modulo n.
So for fixed n, we have
another equivalence relation.
So now given those, we can start
defining equivalence classes.
So what is an equivalence class?
That's actually everything
within that class
is related to itself.
So the equivalence class
of an element, x in a
is equal to the set of
all the elements in a that
are related to x
by our relation R.
So we denote this
equivalence class.
So this is denoted by x
with brackets around it.
So let's put it into a formula
and give some examples.
So the formula for
this in mathematics
would be the set of all the y
such that x is related to y.
So as an example, we can do the
one that we started off with.
So let's again look at x
is congruent to y modulo 5
and look at the
equivalence classes.
So one of them, for
example, we could look
at the equivalence class of 7.
We were looking at
this one already.
Well, what are all the
y's that are actually
congruence to 7 modulo 5?
Well, there are a whole bunch.
We have minus 3
and we have 2, 7,
we have 12, 17,
and 22, and so on.
And we add 5 to all these and
this is the equivalence class
that belongs to 7.
Now notice that the
equivalence class of 7
is actually equal to the
equivalence class of 12.
It's the same set.
Everything that is
congruent to 12 modulo 5
is also congruent to 7 module
5 and this is, again, equal
to say, 17, and so on.
So now we can start talking
about a nice property
that equivalence
classes have, which
is that the equivalence classes
together partition the set A.
So I will need to define
first what a partition is.
And it's defined as follows.
A partition of A is a collection
of this joint non-empty sets A1
up to An and they're
all subsets of A.
And the union of all
of those is actually
equal to the set A.
So who's union is A.
So let's have a look,
again, at this example
and see whether we
can figure out what
the equivalence classes are.
So the example is, well,
we can have everything
that this actually
a multiple of 5.
That's this one class.
So we have minus 5, 0, 5,
10, and we go all the way up.
Another equivalence
class is, well,
we just add 1 to each of those
elements here, so if minus 4
is congruent to 1, modulo
5 is congruent to 6,
modulo 5 congruent
to 11, and so on.
And so we can continue and we
actually see that we minus 3
is congruent to 2, to
7, to 12, and so on.
That's the one we had up there.
Another one is
minus 2, 3, 8, 13,
and we have minus 1,
4, 9, 14, and so forth.
So these are all the
equivalence classes
because now we look around.
If we add one more
2 minus 1, we get 0.
So we get 0, 5, 15, and
so on and that's exactly
the same class as this one.
So we see that for this
particular example,
we notice that these equivalence
classes are a partition of all
the integers.
Turns out that this
is a general property
and we're not going
to prove this.
That's pretty straightforward,
so you should actually
think about it yourself.
Let's keep this up
here and take this out.
So the theorem is that every
equivalence relation on a set A
can be partitioned in
its questions classes.
So the theorem is
the equivalence class
of an equivalence relation on
a set A form a partition of A.
Now, I'm not going
to prove this.
It's actually really
straightforward.
You should really look at this
and see that you can prove this
with the properties,
the property
definitions, and the definition
of an equivalence relation.
So this is as far as we go
is equivalence relations.
And so now we will continue
with partial orders.
Again, we go through
a few definitions
and then at some point,
we'll be able to prove
a few interesting properties.
So let's talk about
partial orders.
So notice that we have shifted
now from in this diagram
over here, in this table,
from this pattern that you
were first interested in.
Now, we go to partial
orders and the difference
is going to be that we
do not have symmetry,
but we do have antisymmetry
and that brings out
a whole different structure.
So a relation is-- it's in
brackets I put here-- weak,
I'll explain in a
moment why I do this.
It's a weak partial
order if it is
reflexive, and antisymmetric
and transitive.
So why do I put weak up here?
Well, if you look in the book,
there are two definitions,
one is a weak partial order,
which is with reflexivity
and another one is a
strong partial order.
And that one has a
property that I did not
talk about here
called irreflexibility
and it's something that I will
not talk about in this lecture,
but you should read about
it and all these properties,
all the theorems that we talk
about right now also hold
for the strong version
of a partial order.
But for now, let's just
call partial orders
those that are reflexive,
antisymmetric, and transitive.
Well, we already saw a
few examples up here.
We have divisibility, which has
this property and also the less
than or equal relationship.
Now usually what
we do is, instead
of using a capital letter R,
we will use a relation symbol.
So a partial order relation
is denoted differently,
is denoted with something
like that instead of R. Now
the reason for that is
because we have actually
will show that there's
a partial order,
so this name does
not come by itself.
It turns out that we can give
an order to the order ranking
to the elements, one element
is less than another and so on.
So let's keep this over
here and change up here.
So an example that we will talk
about in the moment, but first
let me introduce
some more notations.
So we call the pair A with
this relationship symbol
is actually called a
partially ordered set.
And we also abbreviate
this by calling it a poset.
Now, in a poset,
again, can be described
by means of a directed graph,
so we can do that as well.
So poset is a
directed graph such
that it has the vertex
set A and the edge set
is defined by the relationship.
So the edge set is
actually this thing.
Notice that in our definition,
this is actually a set, right?
It's still a set.
It's a set of tuples, of
pairs, and we can, again,
create a directed graph by using
this, so nothing has changed.
But for posets, we can actually
create a more sort of easier
to read sort of
representation, which we'll
call a Hesse diagram,
which is also a graph
and let me give an example
to explain how that works.
So I think we can take this out.
So the example is, imagine
that a guy is going to dress up
for something very formal.
So how does he start out?
So let's have as vertices in
the graph, in this diagram
or the elements of A is going to
be all items that he will start
to put on and start wearing,
so his pants, his shirt,
and so on.
So let's have a look.
So what do you start off with?
Well, maybe your underwear
would be a good idea.
So this could be a first
item that you want to put on.
So let's have the relation that
we are interested in to be one
where we say, well, I first
need to put on my underwear
and only after that I can
put on my pants, for example.
So that makes sense too.
And since I'm doing something
very formal later on,
I better first put
on my shirt because I
like to tuck that into
my pants, but it's not
really necessary to
first put on my underwear
or first put on my shirt.
I can do either of the two.
So we're getting sort of
the I don't care so much.
I want to put on a tie,
put on a jacket as well,
and after the pants, I
need to put on my belt,
but I like to finish all that
before I put on my jacket.
And I also have my right
sock that I like to put on
and I need to do this first
before I put on my right shoe.
That makes sense.
And I definitely like to
finish putting on my pants
before I put on my shoes.
So let's have a preference
relationship over here as well.
But I do not really
care, actually.
I can put on my socks
first and then my underwear
and then my shirt.
I don't mind so much.
I also have my left
sock and my left shoe.
And again, I like
this to be preceded
by putting on my pants.
So this could be a relation,
a sort of a description
of a partial order.
Well, because it's
a Hesse diagram,
so let's talk about
it a little bit
and then I will define what the
official definition of this is.
So let's first look at this.
So this is a partial order.
It means [? a ?] percent
of partial order,
so it's reflexive.
The pants are related to
themselves, so I put them on.
Before I put on the pants, I
need to put on the underwear,
but if I need to put on my belt
after I put on my underwear,
then also I notice I first
need to put on my underwear
before I put on my belt.
So you have transitivity
in this example.
It's also the other property
is that it is antisymmetric.
It's not true that I can first
put on my right shoe and then
my right sock, so we only
have one direction over here.
Now, I did not put
in all the edges
that are possible for
this partial order
because if I really
want to continue this,
if I really want to create the
complete directed graph that I
talked about over here-- I think
it talks about it somewhere--
over here, I can create
a directed graph that
has its vertex set A, which
are all the items that I want
to put on.
And in that set that has all
the different relationships.
Now, this is only
an abbreviated form.
This is a Hesse
diagram, but if I
would look at a
directed graph, then I
would need to look at the
closure of this whole thing.
That's how I would call it.
And I know that, for
example, this underwear,
by transitivity,
is also less than
or equal than or
related to the belt.
So in a full graph, I would
have another edge over here.
And in a same way, I would
have an edge from here to here.
I would have an edge over
here by transitivity.
Also I can see that the
shirt goes before the pants,
before the right
shoe, so the shirt
is also related all the
way to the right shoe
and similarly to the left shoe.
I also have that I have
self loops in here,
like a tie is related to itself,
a jacket as well, and so forth.
So I can put in all these
extra edges and as you can see,
this will be quite a
mess, so the Hesse diagram
is a much nicer,
official interpretation
of what's going on.
So let's define what this
really is and then we'll
continue with some nice
properties of this structure.
So what is a Hesse diagram?
A Hesse diagram is
really one in which I
use the set A as the vertices.
So it is a directed graph--
a different one than the one
that we talked
about it up there.
So it's a directed graph in
which we have the vertex set A,
but the edge set is a
little bit different.
So it is the edge set
that corresponds to this,
but they subtract a whole bunch.
First of all, we remove all
the self loops that we have,
so minus all the self
loops and we also
take out all the edges that
are implied by transitivity.
So that's a definition
of a Hesse diagram.
Now, when we look at the
Hesse diagram over here,
so let me take out these
nodes again or these edges.
So looking at this
Hesse diagram,
you really see a nice
structure in there.
It seems like we can talk about
smallest elements like a shirt,
just like a small element.
It's sort of less
than or equal to
if you think about this
as being the 3%, then
the tie and the jacket and
the pants and the right shoe
and so on.
So you can see a clear order
in this particular graph.
So let's have a look at this.
When I look at this graph, I
also do not see any cycles.
I do not see that the
shirt is less than
or equal to the pants.
It's related to the right shoe
and then it's related to itself
again, so I do not
see any cycles.
And this turns out to be
general property of posets
and that's what we are
going to prove next.
So let's do that over here.
So you see that
there are no cycles
and it's a general property.
So the theorem is that a
poset has no directed cycles
other than self loops.
Now, notice that this
property is really necessary
to have a proper representation
by using a Hesse diagram
because otherwise, if you have
a big, directed cycle, then only
one of those edges would be
part of the Hesse diagram
and all the others are implied
by transitivity sort of.
And that is getting
a little bit messy
because then we do not really
have a unique representation.
But luckily, there are
no directed cycles.
So how do we prove this?
Well, let's do this
by contradiction
and see what happens.
So suppose the contrary.
So suppose that actually
there exists at least two,
an integer, at least two, so
at least n distinct elements,
a1 all the way up
to an that form
a cycle, so such that you
have a directed cycle.
So we would put it
in formula like this.
a1 is related to a2 to a3 and so
on all the way up to an minus 1
an.
And we have a cycle, so
this goes back to a1.
So why would this
be a contradiction?
So maybe you can
help me out here.
So what can I already
derive from those properties
that I have over here?
So I know that the partial
order is antisymmetric,
it is transitive,
it's reflexive.
So how can I get to
a contradiction here?
So let's think about
it a little bit.
Is it possible, for example,
that we could violate
the antisymmetry of the poset?
So can we find maybe two
distinct elements such that
say x is related to y
and y is related to x,
but it's not true
that x is equal to y.
For example, if you
have very small cycle,
say a1 is related to an and
then related to a1, again,
well, then I would
have that a1 is related
to an and an is related to a1.
We should have that an is
then equal to a1 but, that's
not true because the issue of
distinct elements over here.
So that seems to be
an interesting idea.
So maybe we can prove
something of that type.
So can we actually show
that a1 is related to an?
We can write what kind
of a property of a poset
do we use here to
make that happen?
I heard something
vaguely, a mumble.
Yeah, the transitive property.
So how do we do it?
Well, we take those
three together
and we conclude that a1
is also related to a3.
We have a4 over here, so
together with this one,
so a1 is related to a3
and a3 is related to a4.
We have that a1 is related to
a4 and you can use induction
if you want to be
very precise here,
which you should, actually,
but I will not do this.
So you will use induction and
go all the way to the fact
that a1 is actually
related to an.
But wait a minute.
We also have this
particular property
and a1 is not equal to
an by our assumption.
So we get a contradiction,
which means that what
we had over here is not true.
So actually, for
all n, at least two,
n distinct elements
a1 up to an that--
well, we have the negative of
this, so there is no cycle.
So this is a great
property, so now we
start to see why a
poset is actually called
a partial ordered, right?
Because there's
no directed cycles
other than the self
loops, so we sort of
have a ranking to the elements.
We can say that
really one element
is ranked less than another.
So this one is ranked
less than this,
it's ranked less than that,
and it cannot circle back again
and say that this one is ranked
less than this because they
don't have cycles, so that
makes a really consistent story.
Notice that this was different
when we talked about tournament
grass, for example.
That was a very
different structure
and we could not think
of a winner in there.
But in this case,
we have a ranking.
And this leads us to a
more general discussion.
But before we go into that,
I'd like to write down
a conclusion of this theorem.
So after deleting the
self loops from a poset,
we actually get a
directed acyclic graph.
And that's what we
defined last week as well.
So a directed acyclic graph
and we abbreviate this
as D-A-G, a DAG.
So that's a very special
property for the poset.
Now a partial order has elements
that cannot be compared,
for example.
Like in this case, these two
have absolutely no relationship
with one another.
Even through transitivity, I
cannot conclude that either
the right sock is related to
the underwear or the underwear
related to the right sock.
And that makes it
a partial order.
It's possible that you have
elements, pairs of elements,
that are incomparable.
So let me write this down.
So what we really
want to though,
is that we have some kind
of consistent ranking
that we can create for
a partial ordered set.
But for now, we know that
certain pairs cannot be
compared to one another and we
would like to achieve something
like this.
So that's why we start to
talk about what it means
if a and b are
incomparable and this
is, if neither a is related
to b nor b is related to a.
And we say that a and
b are comparable well,
if a is related to b
or b is related to a.
Now we can have a
very special order
which we call total order.
In a total order, it's
actually partial order, but all
the elements and comparable.
So it's a partial order in
which every pair of elements
is comparable.
Now, maybe you can
think about the Hesse
diagram of a total order.
What would it look
like if we have
that all the elements
are actually comparable?
Do you have any idea what
kind of a graph would that be?
So in this case, we had the
partial order because we see
that certain items
cannot be compared,
but what happens if
you have a total order?
For example-- yeah.
Do you have a--
AUDIENCE: It would
be a straight line.
MARTEN VAN DIJK: Yeah.
That's correct.
It will be straight line.
And it will look something
like this and it keeps on going
and over here also,
keeps on going like this.
So it's a straight line.
If it's a finite set, we
have a finite line, so just
a finite number of vertices,
but otherwise, it's
just an infinite line or a
half or semi infinite line.
So why is that?
with every two elements, it
can be compared to one another,
so you can rank them
essentially along this line.
So if you think about
the integers and the less
than or equal to
relation, well, we
see that one is less
than or equal to 2
and 2 is less than or
equal to 3 and so on.
So they all are put in Hesse
diagram as a straight line.
So that's is very special order.
We have a ranking
with the total order
through this straight line.
It will be great if you
can also rank the elements
in a partial order
and that's what
we're going to talk about next.
We're going to talk about the
topological sort of a poset.
And what it really means is
that we're going to extend,
essentially the partial
order toward a total order.
And by doing that,
we will manage
to put a ranking
to all the items.
Let me define what's
happening here.
So this is about equivalence
classes and you remember this.
So what is a topological sort?
So the idea is that
if the total order
is consistent with
a partial order,
then it is called
a topological sort.
So let me redefine it
again more formally.
So what is it?
A topological sort of
a poset is formally
defined as a total order.
It's a total order that has the
same set of items of elements A
but has a different
relation that we
will denote by a subscript, t.
And this is such that
well, the original relation
is contained in the new one.
Notice that these
also denote sets,
so that's why I can
write it like this.
So this set that is
defined by this relation
is a subset of this relation.
So it simply means that
if x is related to y,
then it also implies
that x is related
to y in the total order.
So we're interested
in figuring out
where we can find such
a topological sort.
Is it always possible to do so?
Now it turns out that
every finite poset actually
has a topological sort and
we're going to prove this.
How do we do that?
So let me first write
out the theorem.
The theorem is that every finite
poset has a topological sort.
The basic idea is that
in order to prove this,
it's that we're going to look at
a minimal element in the poset.
For example, in the diagram,
we have four minimal elements.
I will define what that means.
The left sock and the right sock
and the underwear and the shirt
are all at the top
of the Hesse diagram.
Those are minimal elements.
I just take one of them,
take it out of the poset
that I'm looking at.
I will get a smaller
poset and recursively, I'm
going to construct
my total order.
So it's a total order
on a smaller poset
and then I add the
minimal element back to it
and then I get a total
order for the whole thing.
So essentially I'm
going to use induction
and before I can do that, I'm
going to first talk about what
it means to have
a minimal element
because that's what we need.
So x in A is called
minimal if it's not true
that there exists a y in A,
which is different from x,
but such that y
is smaller than x.
So there exist no other y
in A that is smaller than x.
Then if that's true, we
call x a minimal element.
And in the same
way, of course, we
can talk about a
maximal element.
It's exactly the same,
but at the very end,
we will have the reverse,
so x is related to y.
Now, it turns out that not every
poset has a minimal element,
actually.
So as an example, we may
consider the integers,
the negative and positive
numbers and then less than
or equal to relation.
There does not exist
a minimal element.
You can always find
a smaller elements.
So it's not really true
that every poset actually
has a minimal element.
It turns out though
that in a finite poset,
we do have minimal
elements and then we
can start doing the
proof by induction.
So let's prove this, that
every finite poset has
a minimal element.
So let's do that up here.
Actually, we do need
this theorem later on.
So let's start out here.
So the limit that
we want to prove
is that every finite poset
has a minimal element.
And in order to do
that, we're going
to define what is
called a chain.
And a chain is this
sequence of elements that
are related to one another.
It's a sequence of
distinct elements
such that a1 is smaller
than a2, smaller than a3,
and so on up to some at.
And the length of a chain
we will denote by t.
So this is going
to be the length.
So now let's have a proof of
this lemma and with that lemma,
we will then be able to prove
the theorem that we want
to do on the topological sort.
So let's see how we can do this.
So what's the proof going to be?
Well, you want to
construct a minimal element
that we think would be minimal
and how are we going to do it?
We're going to look at the
chain that has the largest
length, the maximum length.
So let a1 related to a2 and so
on to an be a maximum length
chain.
Now, I'm cheating
here a little bit
because how do I know that
such a chain actually exists?
Does there exist a
maximum length chain?
So that you may want
to think about it.
So it actually does exist and
if you think about it yourself,
then you will
actually use the fact
that we use a finite poset.
If you have a finite
number of elements,
well, the maximum
length chain can
be at most the number of
elements in the poset,
so you always have
a maximum number,
but you can prove
it more formally
by using the
well-ordering principle.
But I will not do that here, so
we issue for now that this just
exists, but you can prove it.
So let's look at two cases.
So what do we want to do?
We want to show that a1 is
actually minimum element.
So let us consider any
other element in the set
and then we have two case.
Either a is actually
not a part of a1,
a2, all the way up to an.
Well, in that case, if a is less
than a1, well, what goes wrong?
I can put a up front here.
It's a different element
from all the others.
I get a longer chain.
So that's not possible, right?
So we'll get a longer chain
and that's a contradiction.
So this assumption is not true.
So it's not true that
a is less than a1.
What's the other case?
The other case is that a is
an element of one of those.
So it's one of
those in the chain.
Now, let's have a
look what happens if a
is less than or equal to a1.
But wait a minute.
If a is one of these and a
is less than or equal to a1,
then I will have a
cycle, a1 is less than
or equal to a is less
than or equal to a1,
but you just showed
in the theorem
that there are no other
exit cycles in a poset,
so this would imply
that we have a cycle.
And according to the theorem up
there, we have a contradiction.
So also in this case it's not
true that a is less than a1.
Now this is the definition
of a minimal elements.
So let's have a look
at this definition.
We have proof now that for every
possibility every possible item
or element in set
A, it's not true
that that new element
is smaller than a1.
So a1 is actually
a minimum element
according to the definition.
So a1 is minimal, that's
what we have shown.
So great.
We have shown that there
exists a minimum element,
so this is the
end of this proof.